you know usually this is the part of the
show where i say
man and we have an amazing program
tonight
yes i'm gonna be honest with you i'm not
sure what kind of a program we have
tonight
we have news a little bit of an unusual
situation
going on with our show and that is that
tonight
uh we were supposed to be having kumail
mangiani on the show
yes and we love him i'm gonna go out of
my way and say we love that guy he's a
great guy
yeah yeah very funny man
good man he's shooting
silicon valley yeah and there was some
kind of snafu when they're in their
shooting schedule
and it worked he's in marina del rey
shooting a scene and he can't
get here we found that out half an hour
ago
while i was having my nap that i have
i was having my pre-show nap andy was
having his bath in heavy cream
that's right and they came in and they
said kumao can't get here
right when you're a show that's based on
just interviewing one guest
and that guest doesn't show up you're
really screwed
i mean this could end up being the guy
right here you know
you better get some magic don't you
buddy yeah
it's gonna hurt your selling weed for
about a half hour but
you'll do that on the side yeah i love a
guy who's still selling weed illegally
in california yeah who says he might own
a dispenser yeah no no no
he's still going around like
[Applause]
yeah so what we're going to do is we're
going to figure this out as we go along
i think it's exciting you know so much
of tv today is
pre-programmed but that's not the
show tonight the show tonight we really
don't know what's gonna happen
we're figuring it out as we go
please what is your name my name is
francisco
cool to meet you it was a huge mistake
to bring you up here
but i got my pal here we have a great
show we're gonna make it up as we go so
stick around we'll be right back
you